And now it's to you, Scoutmaster.
["The Star Spangled Banner"].
So a couple scouts get together.
They think they're going to do something nice for their scoutmaster.
They're going to get him a gift.
They decide let's get him a puppy.
He likes dogs, It would be great.
So they go to the local animal shelter.
They go to the attendant.
They say, hey, we'd like to get a dog for our scoutmaster.
The attendant looks at him and says: I'm sorry, boys,
but you know we don't do trades anymore
And we found that it's really hard to get scoutmasters adopted out anyway.
["The Star Spangled Banner"].
Hey, this is podcast number 63..
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Well, this week we finally moved into the new home
for the Scoutmaster blog and the podcast and the newsletter.
That's right, we sure did.
We have a new URL, new place online
that's called scoutmastercgcom,
And if you try and go to any of the old web addresses,
you're going to find yourself at scoutmastercgcom.
because of some clever webby thing that's happening,
that redirects you to the new spot,
And I've gotten a couple of nice compliments about it
and I sure do appreciate it.
We put a lot of work into it
and hopefully it will be a growing resource as time goes by.
I wanted to point out a couple of things.
First of all, there is a high adventure destinations map
and there's going to be a growing database of different places
that you can take your scouts for high adventure.
I mean, we all know about the Big Three,
We know about Philmont and Seabase and Northern Tier
and sometimes we can make it there and sometimes we can't.
but every troop should have a good, strong high adventure program
and there are ways to make that happen
that don't cost a mint of money
or take a whole lot of messing around and planning,
and we're going to make a commitment to bringing you resources
and destinations to make exactly that happen.
Greg wrote in and said this.
He said I really appreciate having the show to listen to
as an aspiring scoutmaster for my troop.
Well thanks, Greg,
It's good to have you out there listening.
Kevin Smith wrote in and said this:
wrote in with this story.
He said we were on a day hike in the Superstition Mountains
near Phoenix. that gives you an amazing view
of the entire Valley of the Sun.
One of our young scouts had slipped a few times
and finally he took a spill where he slid about 10 feet.
Now he wasn't hurt, but he was a little shaken up.
so we got him up and dusted him off
and then, with no prompting,
two older scouts took his pack
to make his journey a little easier.
We talk about character building,
but when you witness acts like this,
you know you're going in the right direction.
I absolutely love your podcast
and make a point to pass it on to all the leaders
that I bump into.
Your insight and experience as a scoutmaster
has helped me guide our scouts.
Sir Robert would be proud of your efforts,
And that's from Kevin Smith.
Thanks very much, Kevin.
I sure do appreciate it,
and thank you for the kind words
and a good story too.
Mike Stock, who is an assistant scoutmaster
in Troop 620 in Liverpool,
wrote in and said:
I just wanted to shoot you a quick note
to tell you two things.
Number one, the new site looks amazing.
Well, thank you, Mike.
Number two, you've proven to be
an amazing resource for me
as I transition into my new role
as an assistant scoutmaster.
My son is completing his first year of scouting
and I'm not sure who's having more fun,
him or me.
Your podcasts and newsletters
have been invaluable,
and I wanted to say thank you.
Some of the topics make it seem
like you're attending some of our meetings
and your advice is helping us
get through some difficult situations.
We're currently implementing the patrol method
as it was originally intended.
It's rocky times, but worth every bump.
Thank you for doing what you do.
I wanted to make sure you knew
how much I appreciate your work
and commitment to what you do.
Well, thank you so much, Mike.
I sure do appreciate your kind words.
The reason it sounds like
I'm at your troop meetings
is because every troop meeting
is pretty much the same.
Boys aren't all that much different,
Scoutmasters aren't all that much different,
Places aren't all that much different.
We all deal with the same thing.
It's pretty amazing.
We have a small international audience,
but I would bet that
it's pretty much the same,
not just all over the country,
but throughout most of the world.
to tell you the truth,
Last time around in podcast 62,
we talked about no shows
and scouts kind of showing up
at the last minute for camping trips,
and that was through a call-in question
from Todd Grady,
And you know that you could call in too,
and you're going to find out about that
towards the end of the podcast.
Scoutmaster Jerry, who has the SMM podcast,
was kind enough to write in
and he says
the way our troop handles the no shows
is pretty simple.
If you say you're going,
the money for your share of the patrol's food
automatically comes out of your scout account.
If you don't show up
or you bail out at the last minute,
your food is covered
and your patrol just gets to eat more.
That's a pretty good plan, actually
I like that plan.
So you say you're going,
you know your name gets put on the roster.
hey, then you know
your money comes out of your scout account.
it pays for your food.
How about that?
I think that's not a bad idea.
If we have somebody show up at the last minute,
we don't turn them away,
we make room and it always seems
there's enough food to go around
amongst the patrols.
That's a good plan. Jerry
Todd, did you hear that one?
Because Todd had called in
with the original question about this
and he and I did a little back and forth
over email in the ensuing week.
He wrote first and said
thanks for the advice.
I appreciate not excluding boys from events,
but I also have trouble completely letting go
and taking a whatever happens, happens attitude.
If there's no accountability.
I can pretty well guarantee
that we'll see more of the same.
Well, you know, Todd,
I know that my advice that I gave you
on last week's podcast
was a little fuzzy and indefinite,
So let's talk about this for a moment.
We do need to have a practice and a policy,
That's right,
But we also need that policy
and that practice needs to be infinitely flexible.
80% of everybody will get it
and they will do what they're supposed to do,
and 20% will be a bit of a problem
and that'll make you crazy,
because it makes me crazy too,
But you learn to live with it.
So it's not just, you know,
basically totally thrown up your hands.
It's kind of throwing up your hands 20% of the time,
which really isn't all that bad on average,
to tell you the truth,
And I did remind Todd
to talk to his patrol leaders council about this
and he wrote back and said
he was absolutely going to do that.
He said that I think the problem we have
is usually with just a few scouts-
one or two consistently
and one or two additional at each event.
We need to address the problem with those
who consistently abuse the generosity
of their fellow scouts.
Well, yeah, yeah, I agree
We need to watch trends like this.
If it's happening month after month,
there's a problem.
It's just once in a while,
You know, that's kind of anomalous.
And this is where you know
I like Jerry's solution.
And the reason that we're going on and on and on
and talking about what should be a relatively simple thing
is because I think it gets at the heart
of some very broad, basic,
underlying concepts of scouting
and the ways of inclusion
and making sure guys get to do things
and dealing with kids who are, you know,
13,, 14,, 15 and have no brain,
and parents who are sometimes disconnected,
and things like that.
These are things. well, you know, you would think,
well, we just make a rule
and that's the end of the matter.
Well, you know, rulemaking doesn't take us very far
And that's why we do talk about this
and that we carry on about it.
So, Jerry, I really appreciate your input on the question.
Todd, I appreciate you sending the question
in the first place and sticking with me
through the discussions we're having about it.
So this week, in just a moment,
in Scout Mastership, in seven minutes or less,
we're going to talk about Scout Master conferences
And then after that we're going to talk
a little bit about some basic ideas
for new Scout Masters.
basic ideas for new Scout Masters.
That's going to fill the podcast this week
and I think we had better get started, shall we?
Scout Mastership in seven minutes or less.
Once a Scout has completed all the other requirements
he needs for a rank,
he is left basically with two.
One of them is a Scout Masters conference
and the other one is a Board of Review.
Now, we've talked about Boards of Review
and things like that, and as a Scout Master,
you don't get to participate in Boards of Review,
but you do get to do Scout Master conferences.
As a matter of fact, you get to do
Scout Masters conferences
and then you get to participate in the Board of Review.
As a matter of fact, you get to do
just about all the Scout Master conferences.
so it's an important piece of the job
that we do need to discuss from time to time.
Now, why do we engage in this kind of one-on-one review?
Well, the relationship between a Scout and a Scout Master
is important for the troop's health
and for the troop's success.
The Scout Master needs to watch the troop dynamics
to see who's showing leadership
and who's holding back,
who might be a little shy
with the younger Scouts, who's skilled in outdoor activities, etc.
Further, the Scout Master is watching
the individual Scout to determine
whether he's advancing, whether he's having fun
and whether he seems eager or uneasy.
Now we always emphasize that
this is not an opportunity for a Scout Master
to sit and retest a Scout's skills.
I think that's the greatest single misdirection
experienced in many troops.
Once we are disabused of the misconception
that we should be retesting or testing a Scout
during a Scout Master's conference,
we can move on to more important business.
A Scout Master conference is really just a chance
to talk to a Scout about how he's doing,
about how he feels about the troop
and his patrol and his role in it,
how he's advancing
and how he's striving to live up to the ideals of Scouting.
Most importantly, the Scout Master conference
can be a way of encouraging the individual Scout.
The Scout Master conference is the most personal method
in Scouting to assess the needs and desires of a Scout
and then to encourage and support him
to learn of his hopes and his fears
and to help him see himself
in the greater context of Scouting
and to encourage his personal growth,
both in skills and in living up to the Scout oath and law.
There are a couple of things that I commonly end up
assessing at a Scout Master's conference.
One is Scout spirit
and one is active participation
in the Scout's troop and patrol.
And there's a very simple way of doing this,
and one that has never failed me,
and that is I simply ask the Scout to assess themselves.
You know, we look at the requirement that says
this requirement here says: you know,
you must show Scout spirit.
Give me some examples about how you've done that.
Tell me, if you were going to sign this for yourself,
would you be able to?
Do you think you've completed that requirement?
I do the same thing with the active part.
I just say: you know,
do you consider yourself to be an active Scout?
Why do you consider that?
Can you defend that proposition to me there?
And that usually is a way that we can jump off
into talking about other subjects,
talking about other things.
I don't necessarily confine the subject of my questions
or of the conference itself to Scout stuff.
I like to ask about family.
I like to ask about school.
You know what's your favorite subject in school?
Is there anything that you really struggle with?
What did your grades look like last time?
Were they pretty good,
You know, get along pretty good with your brothers
and sisters, little things like that.
A lot of younger Scouts are a little more cowed
and tasked to turn at Scoutmaster conferences.
Frankly, you know,
I know that they're kind of scared of me.
I asked my senior patrol leader about this
several months ago
and you know I just said,
why are the younger Scouts scared of me?
And he didn't skip a beat.
He said: well, you have a big beard,
a loud voice and an off-putting manner.
Yeah,
So I try to be nice and personable.
I don't holler and scream or, you know, act badly.
But for some reason
the younger Scouts are a little frightened of me
and we just try and work it out as best we can.
Sometimes it's hard to get them to speak,
but if you ask lots of good, open-ended questions
they will calm down.
You know you have to remember that most boys
who are Scout age are not going to have
regular informal conversations
with adults outside their family.
When you think about it, you know
that's not going to happen all that often,
So it might take them some time
to get comfortable.
I think a lot of times Scouts
are looking for the right answer,
as if they believe I'm trying to trip them up,
and it often takes two or three conferences
before they understand
there aren't any right answers involved.
I've found that if I begin the conference
by asking about subjects outside of Scouting,
they're more likely to open up
when we start talking about Scouting things.
Conferences really need to last
about as long as they ought to last-
Five to ten minutes,
I think that's plenty,
And you should be able to develop
a good idea of what a Scout is thinking
and how he's experiencing his troop and patrol
and how he's experiencing Scouting in general.
You should be able to suss out
if there are any real difficulties.
You should be able to get a profile
of his skills, interests and abilities
And you can do that
within five or ten minutes.
I find my briefest conferences
are for those Scouts who are,
you know, Star, Life and Eagle.
to tell you the truth,
Eagle is usually a very brief conference
because by the time a Scout has reached that point
in his Scouting career,
not just because of age or experience,
but you know, if he's going to be
a Star and a Life Scout
and then become an Eagle Scout,
he's going to spend a fair amount of time
invested in the leadership of his troop and patrol
And that means that he and I
are going to talk on a pretty regular basis
And I'm going to know an awful lot
about what he's doing and thinking
because we're going to have
pretty much an ongoing conference
during those years
that he's part of a troop.
It's hard for me to sit and ask questions.
I already know the answers to.
You know for the most part.
So, finally,
the last part of the Scout Masters Conference,
before I sign the book and send them on their way,
is: do you have any questions for me
And is there anything
that you need to know about
or you're uncertain about as far as the troop
or your patrol is concerned, or how things work?
And you know, let me know
if there's anything that you need
me to help you with,
And it works very well that way.
So let's just review quickly.
a Scout Masters Conference is a good
informal conversation in which you get a profile
of the Scout and his experience
and his patrol and his troop and his scouting in general.
You can find out
a lot about them. You can find out
a lot about their interests and what they're thinking.
You can
find out about what's going on
within their patrol. You can find out
what's going on in the troop. that way,
It's usually a pretty
enjoyable time.
Younger Scouts will be a little
cowed, They won't know exactly how to deal with
this and, you know, despite
every explanation and
reassurance that you give them, they
will continue to be that way, Maybe
for a conference or two, until
they settle down a little bit and
it becomes somewhat easier for them.
So, and then
end the conference
by asking the Scout if
they have any questions.
Five or ten minutes should do it.
Don't make it a big official, difficult
thing. No forms, no papers,
please. No
tests, no quizzes.
I think you'll find that it's one of
the more informative and
more enjoyable tasks that
you have as a Scout leader.
Hi, this is Dr
Paul Auerbach and you are
listening to Clark Green
on the Scoutmaster Podcast.
Well, if
you're listening to this, you probably have a teenage child
living in your home, Maybe a couple.
My sympathies.
No, it's an exciting time of life.
It sure is a lot of fun
and it goes by very quickly.
My teenage child is now
28 and you know,
moving along, doing great,
But every once in a while
I want to look at him
and I want to say: you know, if you just knew
what was going to happen in the next 15 or 20
years. and if you just
listen to what I tell you,
Yeah, it's a
yeah,
that's never going to work.
It's never going to work, but I'm going to give it a try
anyway. I'm going to give it a try with you
because I hear from a lot of people who
are becoming new
Scoutmasters- you know, becoming
new volunteers and scouting-
And I want to tell you- and I
sometimes look at the things that you're thinking
and you're saying and you're doing- and I say, yeah,
you know, if you just knew,
if you just knew what it was going to be like
in five or ten years, you know.
So here's
a try. I'm really
honestly going to give this a try
Because if I could speak to myself
27 years ago when I
became a Scoutmaster, here's what I
would say. I'd say
this: learn as much as you can
from training and reading.
Study the Guide to Safe Scouting
and the Advancement Committees and Policies
and Procedures Manual and the Insignia Guide,
the Scoutmaster's Handbook Especially.
look at Baden-Powell's AIDS to Scout
Mastership and memorize
the Introduction to the Scout
Handbook, Because
that's where all
of the promises that are made to
a Boy Scout when he becomes
a part of our organization are enumerated
right there in that first
chapter. I would tell myself that
you will encounter any number of
cynical old Scouters,
loads of misinformation
and a few real renegades who've recreated
Scouting in their own image. Don't admire
them, don't imitate them, do not believe all
that much of what they say.
I would tell myself that
the culture will change but the basic
motivations, desires and needs
of my Scouts are going to remain the same,
And that
the real genius of Scouting is that it
recognizes and addresses those basic,
unchanging needs. Whatever new
form they have to take on, the fears
and concerns and criticisms of fellow leaders
and parents and committee members will remain
the same.
Almost every imaginable conflict
and problem in Scouting has
already been met and resolved by someone,
So lean on the advice
and direction of experienced help.
As much fun
as it is for you to play the game,
remember that you are the coach
and you're not allowed to get in the game.
You have to let the Scouts play it on their own.
I would tell
myself that Scouts will advance and
participate at their own speed and in their own time.
As they learn to lead,
they'll make a lot of mistakes.
Your personal standard of performance
can't be applied to them, only the standards
that are written into the program,
And every other standard is kind of
suspect.
You do not need to protect the integrity
of Scouting, as much as you may think.
Most of the protections are built in.
All you have to do is stick with the program.
If you do that, the integrity
of Scouting will take care of itself,
just as it has for the past century.
Thank you very much.
I'd tell myself that
ranks and merit badges and various recognitions
aren't mine to bestow on the
deserving, That I can't
set standards above or below
what's already written,
And that I should not throw up roadblocks
or otherwise try to hold a Scout back,
And I shouldn't force them to move forward
either, Because
it's his time in Scouting, not
my time. I would tell myself that
whatever you do, don't try to make things easier.
Scouting has a lot of inherent
inefficiencies
And each has its own purpose.
I'd tell myself not to take things
too personally,
That there's going to be a lot of difficulties
and setbacks. They're not all my
fault- Some of them
are-
And the successes and triumphs
are not all to your credit either.
And finally, I
would say, 25 years from now,
you're going to be happy that you're stuck with it.
So there you have it.
My advice to you, if you're a new Scout
Master, whether you're going to listen to it or not,
hey, that's up to you, But that's what I would
have told myself 27 years
ago.
Well, thanks for listening to
this edition of the Scout Master
podcast. Here's how to keep
in touch. You can read the Scout Master
blog at its new home
at ScoutMasterCGcom.
ScoutMasterCG-
letter C, letter G dot com.
How about that? huh,
You can subscribe to the Scout Master
newsletter by going right to
that website, ScoutMasterCGcom.
Have I said it enough yet?
And the Scout Master newsletter
is a monthly digest of the Scout
Master blog and podcast, with some
great scouting resources around a monthly
theme. Every newsletter
includes a giveaway from one of our
affiliate sponsors.
For the Scout Master podcast to remain
real and relevant and worth listening to, it needs
you to participate, And here's how you participate.
You can email me
at ClarkGreen at gmailcom-
That's C-L-A-R-K-E-G-R-E-E-N-
at gmailcom
with your comments
and your questions,
And you can also call and leave a
voicemail comment or a question
at 484-734-0002..
That's 484-734-0002..
So do be sure to get in touch,
give me a call, drop me an email
and you can be part of the Scout Master podcast.
I need to take a little time and remind you
that the Scout Master podcast
and the Scout Master blog and the Scout
Master newsletter are not official publications
of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America. No, no, no,
it's just me. I have a computer,
a microphone and I like the sound
of my own voice
And we're trying to lend a hand to Scout
leaders and maybe have a little bit of fun
along the way.
Now, before we go,
let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good campaign.
Why? thank you, sir,
Until next time.
Thank you,
Thank you.